I,
I was so young when I was in New York,
I certainly wrote a lot,
but last time I was here I found it
really distracting.
I was hard to stay indoors because I
wanted to be out all the time.
Um,
I think the most important thing is to
just get a ritual down wherever you are.
Process.
Well there's two parts to it.
There's the long term process of a novel
and then there's the daily stuff,
you know,
it's like planning for a marathon.
You,
a,
you set up your training schedule,
you know,
you have your idea.
And I,
I plotted out,
I have to make a huge outline of it and
about.
And then I work every day about nine to
two or three.
I have to get three pages down everyday
and there's usually a point about 150
pages in where everything falls apart.
We're,
all the plans are for not.
The book has become something else and I
have a nervous breakdown and then I
submit to what the book has become and I
keep going
and that's a terrible.
And then a great time.
No one likes to be around me during that
to tell people.
I mean,
I really think it's just
what everyone says.
It's a.
it's willpower kind of a game that
there's.
Because the weirdest part in graduate
school was that the most talented
writers,
we're not the ones who became writers.
It was the dog had once and that.
That's actually talent too I guess is
just being willing to go every day and
stay there until the pages appear every
day and not.
I tell this to my students too.
I'm like,
I know you can write a short story
overnight,
but that's not the job.
That's not a longterm skill.
You need to write a short story over a
month,
every month and I think that's it.
I don't think it's the right decision
for everyone.
You know?
It was,
I was coming from New York,
I couldn't afford anything.
I was having a hard time figuring out
how to be a writer here and I'm going
to.
Montana was a very attractive,
completely different plan and it worked
out great for me,
but
I'm not sure it helped my writing,
you know,
because you have a committee of people
who are also lung young like you and
don't really know how to do it well
either,
so it's a funny committee to be
submitting your work too and you have to
really know the confident in what you're
doing because I wasn't writing like
anyone else there and that was hard for
me to figure out and I think it would
be.
And it's destructive to a novel for sure
because you meet every week with part of
a novel that really what you should
tell you a novelist is keep going until
you finished the draft.
Don't trust anyone
in Montana.
Yeah,
it was,
it was great.
But
then also it was pretty cold,
dark winters.
I guess that helps novel writing to
historically,
but it also helps drinking,
you know,
at those times.
But maybe that helps a novel too.
But I love it.
I go,
I go every year.
You know,
I stay for a long time.
I love going to writers colonies and
pastoral settings where there's nothing
to do,
but
either walk around or read a book or
work on your book and they all seem
helpful
in felonies.
I'm going there and then a month.
Yeah,
I can't wait.
You work all day and produce so much
work and it doesn't feel like work.
It just feels like it feels like when
you start out writing and you just want
to write all the time and you're just so
excited about everything you're doing.
It feels like that.
Again,
it's hard to recreate because a lot of
time it feels like a job.
It's like you're building something
really huge.